[Music]
let me start out by
by maybe disappointing some of you and
maybe encouraging others of you although
the word philosophy occurs in the title
of this a philosophy of quantum
mechanics
this is really a course just on quantum
mechanics it's on quantum theory
it's not particularly about philosophy
it's in the foundations of physics i do
this work
together with the people who sit in
physics departments and people who sit
in math departments
and uh and so the philosophical aspect
is really
merely being particularly clear trying
to be very clear conceptually about
what's going on
but physicists do that good physicists
do that very well
as well as philosophers so there's not
really going to be a lot of philosophy
let me encourage you in the following
sense i i talked to someone and i said
i'm giving a course on quantum theory he
said
do you understand the math and
it's a the math is actually quite simple
there's nothing mathematical
that will stand in anyone's way if you
if you if you've managed to grasp
the following concept mathematical
concept
which i have on the board beside me
we'll get to that
even and odd okay if you're clear on
even and odd
you're golden i'm going to give you a
mathematical proof
i mean it's a real honest-to-god
mathematical proof and it won't require
anything more
than keeping track of even and odd and
it's
perhaps the most astonishing and
surprising thing that's been discovered
i would claim about the physical world
in the history of mankind
but you should be able to understand
everything so if there's anything i
say that you didn't follow it's my fault
it's not your fault okay and you should
in the question session just throw a
rock at me and say
i didn't get that okay there's
absolutely nothing that you should leave
fuzzy in your head or that's too deep
for me
or my mind is blown you know
conceptually or something
right so this is really to get very
clear
on two things and they divide into the
two lectures
the first lecture is what we found out
for sure
which as i say is going to be a really
astonishing thing to find out about the
physical
world and the second lecture is what we
still don't understand
and what the possibilities are although
we don't know
what quantum mechanics is telling us
about the world
different possibilities are being
explored and developed
and you should be able to understand
what those possibilities are
and why they differ from each other now
there's been
a tremendous amount of
mystery that's come to surround quantum
theory
as some of it quite intentionally
niels bohr is the source of a lot of it
and niels bohr was quite fond of mystery
and obscurity um bor
i'll just give you beforehand because
we're going to be talking about
einstein's objections
to the what's called the copenhagen
interpretation or the copenhagen school
of understanding quantum theory and
bohr thought the deep idea was something
he called complementarity
which i'll talk a little bit about but
not a lot but the deal with
complementarity is that you have two
sorts of properties that exclude each
other so you can have either you want
but if you've won you can't have the
other
and the more you have of one the less
you have to have of the other
and and bohr thought it was this
existence of complementarity that was
the source
of all the amazing things about quantum
theory and about the world in general
and he tried to extend it everywhere and
saw complementarity everywhere
uh and so you would have properties that
are complementary so the position and
momentum of a particle were supposed to
be complementary
and someone once asked boar well what's
complementary to truth
and he said clarity
so he was trying to tell you that the
more obscure what he said was
the truer it was and the better you
could understand it the less true it was
which is just you know i mean this is
just a council of despair
but that's completely wrong you can have
absolutely clear
understandable and true
claims that that you should grasp and
and completely understand
now what i want to do is start just
historically to get you a feel
of how contentious the
surroundings of quantum theory were and
i'm going to do it with einstein because
einstein
is known to have been someone who is
very skeptical
or critical of quan of the copenhagen
school
so uh why why did einstein hate quantum
theory and there's a kind of mythology
that's grown up about this
and i'm going to explain the mythology
and i'm going to explain why it is
mythology
um so
oh my gosh i i fixed these and now it's
cutting in the middle of words
oh well nothing i can do about it now so
uh
but in case you can't read it i'll just
read these out aloud right
so there are two uh phrases that are
perennially associated with einstein's
distaste for quantum theory that he
would make these complaints
the first one is god does not play dice
right which he did say the in different
places he never
actually mentions well der alter right
the old man or
herrgat uh verfulnesh right
god does not play dice with the universe
and that
clearly had something to do with the
idea of the failure of determinism
the introduction of probabilities the
idea that
different things could happen and the
other thing he complained about
is translated into english spooky action
at a distance
spookafter right so it's really a
straight translation
spookhoff defend so
that's exactly what it is and these were
the things he didn't like
about the standard copenhagen view
um here
just to get clear about
where einstein stood on both of these
issues
i have some quotations from letters back
and forth
for those of you who plan to sit the
exam
this will come up in the exam it
i've never done a multiple choice exam
before it's a hard
exam i gave it to friends of mine who
were experts in this field and they
couldn't get it right
so i should say also
from what you get i mean you should be
very proud if you follow all this and
walk out of this tent and understand
this
you will understand more about the
foundations of quantum theory than an
average
physics phd and i'm not kidding because
it is not part
of a physics education it just isn't
part of it
to discuss the things i'm discussing
today it's not in the textbooks they
don't give courses on it
some physicists you know in their spare
time
are interested but the average physicist
will be no better off we'll be worse off
than you
after this course all right so this was
in a letter from wolfgang paoli to max
born and
you pick up the the context well enough
so again also einstein gave me your
manuscript to read
he was not at all annoyed with you but
only said you are a person who will not
listen
which this comes up a lot in this
history people who won't listen
uh disagrees with the impression i have
for myself
insofar as a unable to recognize
einstein whenever you talked about him
it seemed to me
as if you had erected some dummy
einstein for yourself which you then
knocked down with great
uh pomp in particular einstein does not
consider the concept of determinism
to be as fundamental as it is frequently
held to be
as he has told me emphatically many
times and he denied energetically
that he had ever put up a postulate such
as
the sequence of such conditions must
also be objective
and real that is automatic machine-like
deterministic so
einstein is denying that he was
insisting on determinism
and that it was a mistake to think that
and and if you said
as many people have said einstein could
never get with the program right he
became kind of a bitter old man because
he could never get on board
with indeterminism because he was just
an old fuddy-duddy okay
this is not true at all uh
letter from einstein to max bourne
i just want to explain what i mean when
i say we should
try to hold on to physical reality
which he very strongly believed in
physical reality
you wouldn't think that would be strange
for a physicist to believe in physical
reality but
things get weird whatever we regard as
existing
real should somehow be localized in
space and time so this was
this was something einstein deeply
believed to this localization principle
that is the real part the real
in part of space a should in theory
somehow exist
independently of what is thought of as
real in space b
that boy they've cut this in strange
places that which really exists in b
should therefore not depend in what kind
of measurement is carried out in part of
space a
it should also be independent of whether
or not any measurement at all
is carried out in space a if one adheres
to this program
one can hardly consider the quantum
theoretical description as a complete
representation of the physically real
now there's a lot in this we're going to
understand better later but here
einstein's saying look somehow or other
here's part of space a here's part of
space b
there should be some physical fact about
what's going on here that can be stated
independently of what's going on here
there should be some physical fact about
what's going on here that's independent
of here
and what's happening here should be
independent of whether or not you're
doing an experiment over here
so you sort of see how this is
non-locality you can sort of see how
if you denied this you might say that
spooky action at a distance
how could my doing an experiment over
here have some
immediate effect far away
that's what einstein worried about
now to continue watching this video
click the link in the top left or in the
description below
or visit iai dot tv for more debates and
talks from the world's leading thinkers
on today's biggest ideas